Yes i thought it was one of those of us who was one of us. Well. I'm robin miller and. I'm a member of robb read.
Community. Which is one of the older ones. Established in this area we were as established in nineteen eighty.
As a community. Before that. I had lived on the property. For a couple of years.
And it soon became clear that there was an absurdly large amount of land a single. Widow with at the time no.
No family living with me. And so since i kept meeting. Young people in the area.
Who had obviously had skills and great need for a home base.
I kept thinking we'll this is would be a good idea to to see if we could become a community.
And the whole story of how this has happened this is unfolded over the last twelve years. A couple first. I met.
I had been admiring. These mags and jugs that were in the local craft shop. And had bought several of them.
Because i just liked the the way they were thrown in the design of them. And i was at a. A function in nimbin weird.
Money was being raised to the person beyond i think it's and. Someone introduced. Jeff sterling to me.
And i realized this is the name of the thought it was talking with and found that he and his wife
and family were just about to leave the area.
Having been here for a couple of years and not found any satisfactory place to live and.
It had been for them it hadn't been a great success. So i said hey you know. We've got some land. Here at lilian rock.
Why didn't you come out and have a look. You know we've been looking for people.
Basically people like you with with skills and who want to live in the area.
So they thanked me very politely and said well maybe. Yes. If we've got time before we leave we'll try and get out.
This it to you and.
The next day was sunday i think we were having a workday then the whole i think i was up on the roof
or painting the roof or something and. Suddenly there was a den up but different. Saying hey we couldn't.
We couldn't sleep all night thinking about this. Could we could we come and see the place. And so that was good.
So we would go to the mountains. They came and they looked around and. We had lunch she was and i said.
Yes we'd like to like to take you up on those so that was really the beginning.
I mean it really was a pick up wasn't it. The dance. And the well i came. A couple of.
They moved over a couple of months later and. They've been here ever since and. They've gone through many yeah.
Transfiguration gifts being a part of. Polly being a craftsman. And then. Weaver. This designer.
And now they are the wild turkey filth makers who are exporting their produce products.
Produce so sort of up and down the coast. And running which shops in film making and. And from.
From then on it was a gradual. Gifts brother came. And he settled it and he's a cabinet maker and wanted to and.
So it grew very slowly and gradually. And people lived in tents while lay built themselves. Cabins or shelters.
Do you want me to talk about the. The process of becoming legal process. They is well. The thing that i felt.
Seemed to be important. Was that if people. Needed a place to build a home and needed.
The sort of support that the community. Can give you those were the. Very important criteria.
It wasn't so important that they have. With money. They contribute money to buy she is.
I didn't want money to be the limiting factor. Because after all the place is paid for anyway.
And i wasn't under any particular burden of. It said that it was a matter of.
Was more important to for a sort of sympathetic people. To get together to share the land.
And i think on the whole it worked out that way. And with danny ever had people come by invitation.
There's been a few who've. Sort of. Wrecked up and said hey you know i've got i've just got so much money.
I want to buy a share here and. We have to say. I'm sorry that's not the way. We do things here. In fact.
Sometimes it's. It takes it takes one hundred percent approval before any new one can come to live here.
As a man that is. I think that was. Yes. Another idea that. I head. At the beginning.
And one reason i was particularly bled. Have poly and if. Sterling. Was that they were just creative people and.
I had known from my own parents. Experience that it's very. Often for people who are creative.
In this way to acquire much capital. Basis. So i felt that it would be good if there were more emphasis.
More people who had these. Sort of skills and needed a place to leave. I felt that would be a very important aspect.
To inviting those individuals. To come and live here. Mind you it isn't always enough. And not everybody. Is that way.
But there are a lot. There's a number of musicians. And a number of crafts people.
I think probably in every household there's one or other. But that. They're designed to be a fortunate so the vs.
One thing leading to another. Us has when it. I think the stain from knowing that my parents. Heads.
Today great you should go d. In.
In paying rent even and they had to pay rent full most of them a large if they didn't have enough. To to put together.
You know what was necessary to own their own home. It's my father's or it.
Or my father is an artist and my mother was a writer and. Between them.
I knew that they had quite a hard financial struggle. And in fact.
We never they never earned their own home until i was sort of. In my thirty's probably.
That so that they were constantly having to pay rent for a place to live and.
I just felt that the people who had least. Creative skills and wanted to do that if. Energies to.
Exploring those skills. It would be rather good. To allow them to to live here without too much financial burden. Fall.
I mean there's no effective rein to the cost. Never to be the important thing. But pay back the main. Sort of workers.
Trying to make good. Yes well. I think my parents. I mean they just managed somehow or other. But.
I just felt that i didn't want people. I just thought it would be that. A better way.
If they didn't have to spend most of their income. Paying for rent.
And they could use it in building a house or you know.
Helping with the children's unseen you know a williams yes yes yes yes yes yes. Was it. So yes yes yes..
In a in only in this whole area. Since nine hundred seventy s. Nineteen seventy three which was the.
Aquarius hit it first aquarius first time they had been a number of people.
Becoming interested in building their own homes goes and. The home builders association had become pretty active.
And one of the problems about this was that. There was not much. Consultation there was no.
Nothing in the way of a manual on how to build your own home or. There was very little literature around that level.
To help people like that. And there were. There was one architect. And a number of people who had some skills.
And they were very active. That was a.d. Of course. They were very active in this home builders association.
And the home builders association. In conjunction with. I guess. Liz mall council. Got together. This seminar in in.
No. I think it was about november nine hundred seventy nine and. I know it was just be full the eighty's.
And it at that seminar pull land it was then the minister for the environment dozens. Came and.
After a lot of discussion. And lot of arguments.
And a lot of opposition from a small council and
and other people to lend his we're feeling very threatened by this idea of multiple look and sees poll land.
Came out with this. Some ation. All right we will. Establish a pilot scheme of. Twenty two i think it was.
Well to block it in cities which will be permitted. In the list moshe. Will the stablish a consulting.
To the architects builders will bring out. I think they brought out a low cost country. Housing. Booklet and.
There was generally a sort of an overriding the. The fears and the opposition.
Being put up against multiple occupancies. And of course.
For those of us who had been interested in gain a bad step this form of land use. It was a time of euphoria.
At least that moment of euphoria. And as a result of that. Although we ourselves are not in let's moshe.
But in cuyahoga i felt that it was only a matter of time before the others would be willing to accept the idea of
multiple occupancy. And so i felt all right about trying to go ahead with. Inviting people to come and share.
The land here. This wasn't.
I wasn't unique in there was there were two or three other people in the area who were also.
Who earned less and then you were also doing it it's i think i've been lucky that the people who has sort of.
Well i mean to discuss. Area has somehow or other sort of settled and. We've been able to be a. Yes.
To consolidate the community as well as we have. There was a period of course from from.
Nine hundred eighty when the first. New the first people who invited here.
Came to live here in the early one nine hundred eighty.
Until about nine hundred eighty six i think it was nine hundred eighty seven. That we got.
Official recognition of our right to have a multiple occupancy. On this land. But that was during the time when.
Council. Was going through quite a lot of. Heart searching you could call it. About the wisdom of.
Having multiple occupancies. Mind you they were having them. Anyway. Because there was a lot of people just.
Just settling and living in building and. I felt quite. Sorry for the late. Council inspectors when late started.
Sort of. Telling is this sad story. You know that i. I had no physical wary of. Of even.
Visiting all these blazes let alone inspecting them properly and assessing their long term worse.
But i think eventually accepted that the propositions that they would have to allow multiple up to the east so they
have done it in those. In this corner. Of their. Shara.
Which used to be part of the old or a new show and they excluded. Multiple occupancies from the rest of the show.
At least at the beginning. In fact that. I think has pro rechanged now is they've. We haven't got.
You know horns and green tails and that we really are human beings too and. Maybe it's just as. Adequate and uses.
As any other form of occupancy. So that's just. I think very personal in that my daughter. When i came to nimbin.
Because i guess i must. I can't claim any particular. Marriage out of this.
My daughter had been interested in the place and had been living here for a couple of years.
Not a son had been here for the. Aquaria says to us a little now five. To hitchhike. Up here from school.
With a couple of his friends. But there was no way i was going to allow my fifteen year old daughter to. Come up here.
On her own hitchhiking. So i bundled her. A number of her friends and into the car and we drove up here. And.
So sort of inadvertently. I was it. The name didn't mean that in seventy three although i must confess that it was not.
My initial choose. Well there now i'm very glad that i was experienced at least a little bit of it.
I didn't come back again and. Couple of years later when i visited my daughter who also said.
I came back to visit my daughter. A couple of times. In the succeeding use and.
It was a very stimulating you know very exciting. Place.
Naturally i was appalled by some of the sort of conditions the people were living in like like my daughter had her
first home. Consisted of a piece of plastic. Pinned up.
Tied up underneath the len tan a bush that she had come out of that she was perfectly happy there.
I'm glad to say she's moved on to slightly grander things.
But at the time at the stage she was it was and she was making very good friends she was happy she was healthy and i
and. I really began to appreciate something of what this whole area and philosophy. Was doing. Was about.
And i must state that it was. The young people who sort of taught me. But for them i would have gone on as a sort of.
The standard middle class mum in the suburbs of sydney. It's us.
What's i think there's a lot of the of us trying to be as states.
I think initially when we first came to live here that brown bread. There was a general feeling.
At the end of the seventy's. That we should be trying to live. A lot more simply than we had been living.
And also that we should be exploring different uses of the land. Different uses of agriculture.
Different types of their group culture. Much more towards the line of perma culture and.
Sustainable sort of production rather than. The agricultural monoculture that is the more general.
Let's see other philosophies.
Had when you look at the loss of these sort of grow out of experience then there was a bit of fear i think.
And i know amongst some people. That there would be a world. Collapse of. World supply.
Things like that role in the oil and. The fear that the. That was still a fear of. Nuclear holocaust. Said that.
To live in a place that was at least slightly remote. Likely moral removed from the centers of so-called civilization.
Seemed to be of. Of a positive benefit.
Mind you i don't think we succeeded they will i mean it seems to got closer and closer to hear everything.
In the intervening time and i'm in the feeling how. How remote it all was it has.
And now it just seems as if it's just. Just like a suburb of. The whole east case. The think that the. It was.
It was very much a social experiment. If one can use that word and experiment without having any.
Control system to judge it by that a social experiment in seeing how will one could lose.
In respect to quality of life. On very very little money. Very little income. And that sort of feeling when i look.
When i visit my friends in the city. With their. Well most of the now have got rid of their mortgages. That any just.
And they've got their three hours and you know. Their problems about where they go this year for their holiday.
And such concerns. I feel she who we really have got such a lovely peaceful. And varied quality of life. Here.
And we have a lead to go through those years those strace. Us. There's a lot of people heads.
And i think there is something coming out of the. Us. Of course the main.
I've always said the line product of this community. If you. If you want to talk about product.
As a as a measure of success the product of this community is its children. And the.
The children who are growing up here and have grown up. Over the last four years. Just seemed to be such.
Well balanced lovely lovely. Unstressed. Young people. I guess it's early cards to say it. How they'll end up.
Later on but. But it's a it's a big group of children. Like they're eighteen. I think and.
With the eldest being eighteen years old the youngest being one that they have.
They have more of a community than their adult. Their parents are really in that. They they sort of.
Care for each other they look after each other and. There's a lot of course a little groups. Of age range rule. Six.
That. Get together like. There's a cluster of. Little girls about five little girls all about the same age.
And they form the most wonderful little. Subgroup amongst them. But on the whole. I think.
You know if you want to judge a society by. Anything. This.
The behavior
and health of their children is is one way that it could be ten zero zero zero zero zero zero zero she she has.
My own daughter. Yes. She has. Well she's moved in her desire for home life. As a sort of the normal.
Suburban middle class suburban domestic. Set up with her own room and. You know.
Washing machines and everything that was appropriate in in the suburban households. To this us. Shelter and. With us.
Sleeping bags. And later plastic. Us. Skin loose sheets and. Was tied into a land down a bush.
And us and then through six issues. Homes that she and her partner has. That have built from.
You know simple polls to splendid. Stone and mansions almost. And then she. Right. I want to do something in my life.
I don't want to spend my time. Just washing and. Doing the garden. So he went back as a mature student.
And did nursing. And is now working in sydney is a community in this very happy. If she saw the right sort of work.
Opportunity i think the structure of the legal structure. Well from. Nine hundred eighty on. We gradually came across.
People in the area who were searching for a place to live and. Those of us who were then living on the.
Moralist decided whether or not we would invite them to come and share the land.